this is curtin devina speaking for
alessandro barbosa for all the luxury
cars that forza horizon 5 has to offer
the one i kept coming back to was an old
volkswagen beetle lovingly called avoca
by the mexican locals it was a reward
for a lengthy string of challenges all
taking liberties with what the
recognizable but otherwise unremarkable
car could be with the right love and
care more than that it became a special
car because of what it meant to one of
the main characters in forza horizon 5's
more personal story missions letting her
recount a love of racing that stemmed
from her grandfather's adventures with
this very vehicle this single chapter
encapsulates not only why the horizon
series was endured but how developer
playground games keeps thoughtfully
iterating on it it's not just about the
familiar high octane racing it's also
about the stories that people in their
cars can tell and what it means to those
who continue that legacy
these moments accentuate a more personal
campaign that gives your created driver
more of a voice than previous entries
increasing the conversations between its
ensemble of racing hungry characters
while also giving plenty of
opportunities for its new locale to be
explored outside of the horizon festival
forza horizon 5 doesn't replace anything
with its shifted focus but instead
delivers another stellar open world
racing experience that delicately
balances arcade sensibilities with a
series of simulation routes
mexico is one of the best regions the
series has visited thus far too offering
a stunning backdrop to each race while
also providing varied services and
landmarks to make each one feel special
while the pristine countryside of
britain might have been a bit too
sterile for the ridiculous nature of the
globe trotting verizon festival mexico
fits right in like the australian
outback in forza horizon 3 playground
games turns the map into a tasting menu
for all the features the country has to
offer from densely packed cities to
barren sand dunes and sun-kissed
coastlines the transition from one hub
to another feels natural as you zip
around the map but the visual variety
that each one offers gives each corner
of the map personality in a way that the
series was missing in its last outing
yeah thank you britain forza horizon has
been a technical and visual treat with
each release and this latest entry is no
different despite releasing on both the
older xbox one and the newer xbox series
x and s consoles playground games has
evolved its engine to bring out even
more details from the hundreds of cars
on offer and the gorgeous lighting that
bathes each of your excursions one of
the most impressive improvements is just
the sheer density of the map each corner
is teeming with small details that make
them stand out whether it's complicated
rock formations on the edge of an active
volcano bubbling with a warm orange glow
or the light scatter and destruction
caused by a furious sandstorm forza
horizon 5 is a stunner in both its
quality and performance modes and
especially so on the xbox series x which
is where i played it letting you get the
most out of your new console purchase
the variety of mexico is not just for
visual pleasure either with each of its
own distinct biomes offering small but
meaningful changes to racing services
and weather conditions that change the
way races play out
road races can only be slightly changed
by a rain's slick surface in a storm but
the same weather radically changes how a
mud-covered sprint in a dense forest
needs to be approached for example the
environment allows forza horizon 5 to
introduce new types of races too
including baja events the game's version
of dirt road races that play out over
the messy sand dunes near the coast or
the wild series that reintroduces
cross-country races but with far more
variable surfaces to play with weather
still gets cycled in and out during
real-world week-long sessions but these
are now regulated to seasonal events as
opposed to directly influencing the
entire open world races are also
designed with specific seasons in mind
so that you're not trapped in a week of
conditions that you'd rather skip
entirely it's a small but good
improvement over the system that debuted
in forza horizon 4. progression has also
been slightly tweaked with less of a
focus on moving from one part of the map
to another as you complete events and
instead letting you author which events
you want to tackle and when as you
complete races take on open world
activities and engage with forza horizon
5's latest story events you'll be able
to spend points to unlock new tiers of
the festival this includes unlocking
access to specific race types such as
apex for standard circuit races pr
stunts for daredevil antics or street
scene for dangerous races in crowded
suburban areas each additional point in
each festival type opens up more story
specific events for that type consisting
of multi-tiered story missions and the
more traditional showcase events that
forza horizon has become known
these story events all feature similar
formats that are changed up by the
racing style that they represent
dropping you in the most interesting
parts of the mexican map there are
ancient ruins and derelict airfields
ripe for exploration on the way to
setting up the next big racing festival
that unlocks even more points of
interest on the map
the most interesting of these are the
ones that pair you up with one of the
new team members and citizens of mexico
be it a talented mechanic or budding
university student looking for someone
with high speed data these carpool
sessions bounce between serious and
comical from poignant tales of the
importance of a car to a family and
over-the-top photo shoots that take you
through some of the worst weather the
region has to offer they each layer
familiar events time sprints to an
objective point scoring skill sessions
or massive physics-defying jumps for
example
they each layer familiar events with a
human element that has mostly been
missing from the series hearing your
created driver respond in these
dialogues makes each conversation far
less one-sided too giving your legendary
status as a master class driver more
texture than just a voiceless avatar
that does silly dances on the podium
forza horizon 5 is still miles away from
what you might consider as story driven
but these small detours do wonders for
the overall pacing when there's so much
racing to be done outside of them these
character-driven aspects are what stand
out the most in the latest entry in the
series and one that's required given how
similar it can feel without it the forza
horizon series has established a formula
that's been stuck to quite closely for
several years now and while it
definitely doesn't feel stable in a way
that many other open world franchises
can it doesn't always have the grin
inducing surprises as it used to
playground games has a knack for great
exhilarating races across its incredibly
detailed worlds but there's not enough
here to convince you that this is the
entry to jump in if previous ones
haven't done it for you its changes are
profound enough for long time fans to
appreciate the change but they don't
have a significant influence on the
overall structure that the horizon
series has become comfortable with the
variety of race events can change over
time too especially as the community
engages with the tools that forza
horizon 5 offers to create custom events
each race can be altered by players and
played by anyone online giving the
already expansive number of races even
more replayability over time there are
new types of multiplayer modes too that
join the returning staples from the
previous entry forza arcade turns the
arcade racing into something even
sillier with a variety of mini games
contained in a small area of the map
that you collaboratively participate in
with other nearby players it's a fun
distraction as it stands but it requires
a bunch of players to pause the more
exciting prospect of head-to-head racing
in order to participate in without
offering the same captivating
competitive edge that the rest of the
strong stable of multiplayer modes do
being confined to a small area of the
maps is also counterintuitive to what
makes forza horizon's brand of open
world exploration so fun playground
games has iterated on its approach to
open world design over the course of the
series and horizon 5 epitomizes why it
works so well it's laid out so that
you're consistently rewarded for
engaging with its world even when you're
just moving from one race to the next
speed traps drift zones small duels with
other races and just simply traveling in
style reward you with points that drive
forward overall progression making each
action feel rewarding and purposeful
it's dense with activities without also
feeling overwhelming letting you map out
routes from events that are littered
with side activities that interest you
to tackle along the way in this way
forester horizon 5 is another meaningful
evolution of the series as opposed to a
reinvention but that doesn't necessarily
mean it's a case of more of the same
even when it is familiar forza horizon 5
makes small but thoughtful changes to
its established blueprint that hones in
on the people behind the cars in a way
that the franchise has previously just
glossed over its iterations to
progression are welcome too letting you
focus on the events that you love while
also giving you even more event types to
make effective use of the varied and fun
map that has been designed around
mexico's best hits it's not going to
convince you to give it a go if forza
horizon's brand of racing hasn't done it
for you in the past but forza horizon 5
still stands head and shoulders above
anything else in the genre
[Music]
you